hire have a look at this table on the
left so in this table in each row you
can see following things the name of a
wrestler the number of times that
wrestler has been a champion and the
combined number of days where that
wrestler has been a champion or like the
sum of the length of all their
championships along with the column that
is the rank and this is ranked by the
combined days attribute so this table is
very interesting by itself but if you
look at the right we have a couple of
questions and let's try to answer them
which wrestler had the most number of
reigns so for that you need to go to
number of reigns column right and you
need to mentally sort them and you'll
find out that eight is the highest
number and therefore Ric Flair is the
wrestler you're looking for second
question the average time as a champion
for top two wrestlers now we need to go
the top two wrestlers we can guess that
pertains to the rank and then so we want
the average of these two numbers you
even have questions such as which of the
following wrestlers were ranked were
ranked in the bottom three which the
answers would be all of those and then
after that out of these who had more
than one reign and you can see that's
Dan Severn so the paper that we're
having here is trying to answer
questions like this if given a table as
you can see this is a pretty pretty hard
task and so pretty excited to read this
the paper is called tapas weekly
supervised table parsing via
pre-training by Jonathan hurt seek Pavel
Christophe Novick Thomas Miller
Francesco Pacino and Julian Martin isin
shows full disclaimer I know these
people
so my
be slightly biased all right so you've
already seen the task the task is you
are given a table and a question and
you're trying to answer that now there
is it's not it's not as easy as that but
the table questions come in different
forms as you have seen sometimes you
just need to select a cell from a table
like we have here the first question I
simply most number of rains I simply
select whatever that is so the answer
here is already in the table Ric Flair
and this they call a cell selection task
this is wherever you need to select a
cell the same for this bottom here so
which of the following wrestlers were
ranked at the bottom three and out of
these which one of more than one rain
all of these answers are in the table
somewhere the second thing is what they
call a scalar answer that is when the
answer to be computed is a number that
is not in the table so these average
time here which turns out to be three
thousand four hundred and twenty six is
nowhere to be found in the table so
there actually needs to be a computation
performed by the model and lastly you
have these things called ambiguous
answers now the ambiguous answers refer
to a thing where it is a number that
you're looking for so how many but the
number here is in the table so you can
think of this in terms of training data
if you have a task like this and you
have training data and you just have the
question you just have this question and
you're given the answer to write you can
teach your model either to select this
number here or you can teach your model
that would be wrong right because how
many world champions are there with only
one rain to
we select this cell here is not correct
because that cell even though the number
is two it doesn't mean the same thing
it's not counting right so the correct
program here would be to count the
number to count the cells where there is
a one here which is also two and they
call this situation ambiguous answer so
you might have already guessed that a
single model that does all of this needs
to sort of have multiple modes that's
exactly what they proposed so they
proposed a model that takes in the table
and the question and then in the first
step it selects its mode so the mode is
either the cell selection or it is to
compute something and then whenever it's
a cell selection it simply has a
component to select cells but when it's
a compute it needs to decide in the
second step what to compute and then
also select the appropriate cells so so
this is the model now this stuff like
this has existed for a long time in
these table answering things but the way
we want to do it here is end-to-end with
a single deep learning model of course
because we want to be better than
anything else and the trend in deep
learning is to put more and more into
one model and to have it end-to-end
differentiable alright so you see we
need multiple components right we need
some sort of a mode selector we need
some sort of a Cell collector and we
need a thing that decides if we're in
the compute mode what computation to be
done now let me present the model that
this paper proposes so this paper
proposes to
embed the question here so you can see
here that's the question into a Bert
input so this is a transformer right
here this is Bert or any variant of
birds that you can think of so the
question is embedded as natural language
and then interestingly enough the table
right here is also embedded as language
we'll get to that in a second but the
question and the table we are in the
input and then the model is asked to do
two things first of all it's asked to do
an aggregation prediction so this can
either be one of these programs called
count sum average or it can be as in
seer none
so no aggregation so this handles our
first two components it can decide to
perform a calculation or none and if it
is performing a calculation it can
decide to do a count a sum or an average
now the of course the the model here is
not limited to those computations you
can think of extending this to any
further computation the important thing
is that they have a number as an output
second of all there is a cell selector
so depending on this aggregation
prediction you need some cells like if
you want to compute an average you need
the cells to compute an average over so
the cell selector here will select cells
from the table is specifically it goes
by row and column sorry column and row
since these tables usually they have a
header right this is the table header
where the attributes are listed it makes
sense to first in a first step select
which column you want to select from and
then if once you have a column let's say
this column here in the second step you
say which of the
Scelzi want to select now these can be
multiple but the way the system is set
up its first a column selector and then
a cell selector within that column so
you can only ever get columns from the
same cell in this thing let's remember
that for later all right so this is what
the model does now let's look at the
input the input to the model is this
here now this if you refer from this
before this was in this blue box and
then here you'd have the computation
selection and here you have the cell
selection right so this is this is how
you can relate that so usually if you
input something into a transformer what
you want to do is you want to embed this
into into a token embeddings so first
you want to split everything you put in
into what are called tokens
now tokens are either things like words
or word pieces the important thing is to
have a dictionary for it and each one
gets mapped to a to a vector so this
here is your query you take your query
as a string and you tokenize it and you
get the embeddings from the embedding
table and that's your input right so
it's a sequence of token embeddings and
then you also embed the table and this I
find pretty cool here in this model and
somewhat special is that the table is
actually presented as just natural
language so you can see here the table
is one string it's just a single string
that goes from left to right it's just
the serialized table so this table right
here you can see these are word pieces
so this table if I reconstruct it if I
can attempt
to reconstruct it it is going to be a
table that has as the headers call one
call to these are the names so in that
days before here would be name of the
wrestler and this would be a number of
days right and then here 0 1 2 3 so this
this table right here corresponds to
this string right here I hope you can
you can make sense of that so the table
is just put there as one long string and
then in order to make the model realize
you know what the table is you have
these special embedding so usually in
birth do you have what they're called
position embeddings to indicate where in
the sequence that is so in a simpler in
the simplest case these are embeddings
for the numbers 0 1 2 3 4 and so on so
wherever the position is this you can
all look up in the attention is all you
need video I've made that if you are
unfamiliar with transformer inputs then
also the the segment embeddings simply
indicate am where what a token is part
of so for every token that's part of the
query you see you have segment 0
embedding and for every token that's
part of the table if a segment 1 a
minute this is simply to tell the model
hey this particular token is part of the
question or part of the table then you
have the new things so this paper newly
introduces the following embeddings
column and row embeddings now these for
the question
of course they don't make any sense but
you have to put something here so you
just put column 0 but for the table you
see there is a column 1 and column 2 and
the
exactly so we've seen that this here is
the header of column one and this is the
header of column two and then it goes
back column 1 column 2 column 1 column 2
and you can see here this 0 is in column
1 and this 1 is in column 2 and this in
column 1 again and the same for the rows
so you have row 0 for the headers and
then row 1 for the first two numbers and
row 2 for the second two numbers so this
is all of this so you see these two are
in the first row and these two are in
the second drawer all of this is to tell
the model all of this information down
here is to tell the model how this table
looks so if it wants to select the
second column from the third row it
would look in this information to see
which cell to select and then the last
thing they introduced is this so-called
rank embeddings now as we've seen before
if this first column here is maybe the
sorry the number of days of something so
this is the number of days and this
second one is the number of rains so how
many championships the table can only be
sorted at maximum by one of them so you
wanna sort of for each cell you wanna
tell the model let's extend that table
by two numbers for and one
so for each column you want to tell the
model the ranking of the numbers so here
it's pretty easy this is Rank 1 this is
Rank 2 this is rank 3 further on the
left side this is Rank 1 this is Rank 2
down here and this is ranked 3 so the
model has a well heaven if you give this
information the model have an easier
time to detect like give me the top two
or something like this give me the worst
give me the best give me the highest and
so on the model will have an easier time
doing that so that's why the
ranked here as you can see the zero and
as also the number one are embedded rank
one and the other to rank two because
they're just lower now I don't see I
feel that could have given a better
example than this table I feel you could
actually put real names here to make
clearer not call a one and call two and
I feel you could give a somewhat smarter
content because if you just look at the
picture here you cannot see the
correspondence of these rank tokens
because in essence they are exactly
equal as the row tokens but fortunately
we can read the text oh there's the
table ha
so I have actually have not seen that
but I've discerned it correctly for this
particular for this particular input
alright I think that's the half of the
magic is how you encode the input in
such a thing and this seems to be first
of all a pretty cool idea but second of
all it exactly is what this kind of new
regime of NLP is about is that you
basically put everything as a string you
annotate it in a smart way and that lets
the model figure out a lot of stuff
about the input people used to people
used to do the very different things so
people if given a query and the table
like this what people would do is they
would somehow first of all get the table
headers and and kind of guess the data
types of the attributes and then they
would formulate reformulate the query
maybe also with a neural network maybe
with something else into something like
SQL in order to actually have an SQL
statement to select the correct cells or
perform the correct aggregations and
that is somewhat brittle and
it's just much less deep learning than
this model so I like this part of the
model now the problem of course is as
we've seen in this multi-step process so
how do we first of all if you build if
we want to build a cell selector that's
pretty easy right we've seen this so we
the cell selector is first column column
selection and then second row selection
and this can be multiple rows so that's
fairly easy selecting cells either for
just returning or for aggregation pretty
easy but how do we do the actually the
aggregation selection is also pretty
easy because we can just do a multi
class classifier right so the classifier
will simply tell us I give give us a
distribution and then we see okay the
some aggregation is probably here the
the what the model wants the real
question is how do we train this and how
this is trained is what I find really
interesting so as we've seen they have
training data the training data comes in
the form of tables questions and answers
as we've seen before we don't know how
to get to those answers so when the
question is which wrestler had the most
number of rings we just know the answer
is Ric Flair now they they do again a
two-step process for their training data
that mimics the two-step process of the
model so the first step is is the answer
a number is the answer and number if no
then it is definitely a self selection
task so they if it's not a number they
just restrict themselves to selecting
cells if the answer is not in the table
then that just means that the correct
thing is to select no cells and just say
I can't answer this question if it is a
number then again you have two options
so is it in the table if yes we are in a
weird situation if no not in table then
it is an aggregation so if it is a
number that is not in the table that
means that the answer is a number there
is not in the table that means the
answer must be computed via one of these
aggregations and if the answer is a
number but is in the table then we are
in this ambiguous answer setting where
the it could be that we need to select
the cell but it could also be that the
same number by accident is in the table
but actually needs to be computed from
other numbers and they do this in the
most deep learning way possible is that
they do basically a soft soft decision
here so they let the model when they let
it select what to compute they let it
make a soft decision what do I mean by
that so let's say you have these three
operations count sum and average and you
have the cell selection so the cell
selector will basically tell you I will
select three cells the three cells
contain the number seven the number
eight and the number three all right so
and the question was I don't even know
what the question was but the cell
selector tells you these three cells are
to be selected you do this by simply
selecting the cells where the cell
selector has a higher probability than
one half now your your aggregation
selection module gives you a soft max
distribution over over the
actions so it's not very much count here
maybe that's 0.1 this here is maybe 0.3
and this is the 0.6 what you do is you
simply compute all of them so you want
to compute the count here which is 3 you
want to compute the sum here which is 18
and then you want to compute the average
which is 6 ha I made a good example by
accident
and then you simply weigh the outputs
here by their probabilities so you say
since the model wants 0.1 puts 1.1
probability on the count I'm going to
have 0.1 times 3 plus 8 once 0.3 times
this sells 0.3 times 18 plus 0.6 times 6
now I'm not gonna so this is 6 plus 0.3
plus three point six nine point nine so
that that's how the model computes
things it simply puts probability on
these operations here and then you
simply take a weighted output with
respect to the computation of all those
things now I'm pretty sure that's
completely invalid because for the same
numbers for example the sum is going to
have a much larger like variance than
the average and and and that's somewhat
going the count may be somewhere in
between depending on the numbers so this
just to take the weighted average here
and then of course right so what they do
is they do have this this is the model
output and you have the correct answer
let's say the correct answer was
actually was to compute the the average
so the correct answer is 6 so what they
do is simply they
take the squared error and that's their
loss actually they don't take the
squared error they take a approximation
to the squared error which is square
until some Delta and then it's linear
and this is simply to be a bit more
outlier of us than they do other things
to be more outlier of us but this so
this is the model output and this is the
correct answer
and they simply count on the fact that
this will this will back propagate so if
you want to make these two things closer
if you're the model right you have the
option of simply putting or a weight
from the from the other ones on to the
average operation and that will decrease
the 9.9 because as you can see both of
these numbers will get smaller and no
wait
this isn't it yes sorry so you will it
will decrease these numbers so this is
the output we got from the weighted
average right so if we decrease these
weights you will put weight from here to
here that will bring the number nine
point nine down and that will get you
closer to the answer you're looking for
but you can also achieve this by you can
achieve this even more right so this
nine point nine is too high if we want
to bring the nine point nine down we're
much better off by taking some of that
output and actually putting on this here
because three is the lowest number right
the only agreement here is that we want
to take weight away from the 18 from the
large one so I'm extremely surprised
that this works given that it is so
super ambiguous what the model should do
with these operations and I I highly
doubt that you can extend this so it's
of course agnostic of what these
aggregations are but the to be able to
extend this to many more aggregations is
will I think lead to much more of these
situations where the model is entirely
unsure of where to put the mass of where
to put the weight and I would be
interested to see what happens if you
have a dataset with like 20 or 50 of
these aggregations and not just three so
this is the this is the let's say the
the interesting part here the other if
you go the other way when you have this
cell selection task it is just to select
a cell right and then you simply have
the cell selector that part here that
does the selection that you also to
train every time simply to give each
cell a weight right so this this is
simply the softmax over column and then
the softmax over rows and you can train
that using the cross entropy now
training the cell selector from data is
pretty easy when it's a cell selection
task right because the answer is in the
table and or is not in the table and
then you know to select no cell so you
do have the training data that a
particular cell is the correct cell and
you can train the model to select that
cell but it is actually a pretty hard
task if it is for example you're looking
for an average operation because not
only do you are you not really sure that
it's an average operation you just know
that that kind of gives you the correct
answer
you also don't really know which cells
to select for this average operation
right because depending on which cells
you select and of course that's going to
be a soft selection as well the the
average answer the average will be
different depending on which cells you
select
so they're basically counting on this
loss here to back propagate not only
through the
the selection of the aggregation to
perform but also to the cell selector to
set which cells to to select so from
this weak signal it's almost like the
reinforcement learning problem where you
have the weak signal and you have like a
billion ways to get your number closer
to that signal and not not really
accurate understanding of what you need
to do is you're just relying on the
model through lots and lots and lots and
lots of data to kind of figure out which
natural language questions to map to
which cells selection and aggregation so
this is it's a it seems like impossible
but it it works the last thing we need
to talk about is this ambiguous
answer setting and as you can imagine
it's pretty simple that they also let
the model do in a soft selection between
the cell selection task so no
aggregation and the aggregations to be
performed and basically let the model
figure out itself which one is better to
do an aggregation or to do no
aggregation suffice to say this this
only works for pretty I think it only
works for a pretty limited amount of
tasks pretty limited amount of questions
and you might have spotted there even
these questions that are follow-up
questions which are another thing they
build into the model and I don't I'm not
really gonna talk about this but they do
have this concept as well which I find
may be a bit out of place but maybe it's
just part of their data set somewhere
maybe it's just these companies want to
get into this conversational mode so
everything needs to be context dependent
at the interesting part here is really
the computation of the aggregates and
specifically the question of which of
these aggregations to choose and this
again this is so surprising that it
works and fairly fairly cool I think
that is the gist of the paper they do
extremely thorough evaluations here on
these data sets and ablations to see
what really counts and what doesn't I
don't really want to go into that safe
to say their results are better than
anything else before I believe they I
believe they're actually on par with
another model but in one dataset but
they beat them on every other data set
so that's you know that's cool I don't
think there was a bar attack
never mind I invite you to check out
this paper look for yourself they have
the code online if you want to train a
model like this yourself other than that
thanks for listening if you like this
content please subscribe like comment
tell a friend and bye bye